gérer un vestiaire directeur de
recherche à la fondation d'études pour
le moyen-orient
bonjour révèle c'est d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france on le rappelle
une toute première opération militaire
qualifié de défensive après des attaques
en irak
très précisément qu'est ce qu'ils
étaient visés par ces frappes
américaines et bien sûr une réponse
effectivement à des interventions de
tirs de roquettes dans la fameuse zone
verte à bagdad dans une base qui est pas
loin de la ville de bagdad est aussi
dans une autre installation à euros au
nord de l'irak
donc les états unis sont sont engagés
depuis un certain temps dans un type de
dispositif à qui nous a été décrit dès
2018 et sur une autre zone au sein dans
la chine a vis-à-vis de provocation
l'administration chinoise administration
américaine a précisé nous répondrons pas
forcément de la même façon et pas
forcément sur les mêmes lieux et le
message de toute façon sera clair et
donc on voit ce type de dispositif à
intervenir a actuellement en syrie et en
irak
un problème a créé par des frappes sur à
des installations militaires ou civiles
américaines en irak et bien on répond
aussi par des frappes mais cette fois ci
en syrie en visant adela le lien commun
c'est-à-dire des milices à consonance
iranienne supportant donc le régime
irakien
donc on a un message très clair vous
nous frapper nous vous frappe on est
mais à un point d'équilibré sans
chercher une escalade finalement joe
biden s'inscrit dans les pas de son
prédécesseur dans altrad
je ne suis pas partisan de personnaliser
une politique étrangère parce qu'une
politique étrangère et quel que soit
l'état s'instruit et s'inclut dans le
temps donc al'avantage la différence
entre
la nouvelle administration américaine et
l'ancien c'est sa clarté
ah je pense que l'administration
précédente n'était pas forcément clair
il pouvait y avoir un double discours
dans le cas de l'administration actuelle
sa disco très clair et avec une
détermination dont on vient de voir
effectivement actions et résultats
malgré tout ce qu'elle n'est pas
surprenante cette opération en syrie au
vu des déclarations du candidat john
hayes veulent pas du tout encore une
fois à ne vivons pas la géopolitique
comme une affaire de personnes à la
géopolitique est une structure à une
intervention à autour d'intérêts autour
de ligne de défense est un donc c'est
dans ce cette vision là qu'il faut
comprendre et interpréter les la
continuité des actions américaines dans
le temps sur cette région
parce que cette riposte américaine
intervient dans un contexte particulier
au moment où joe biden attend un geste
de téhéran avant de réintégrer l'accord
de washington s'est retiré en 2018 en a
c'est exact mais aussi il faut noter que
la syrie a dispose de moyens entier rien
puissant à la russie présente en syrie
dispose de moyens anti-aériens puissant
et laissent faire n'est-ce pas et je
tiens à souligner cela parce que c'est
très important
la résolution de la crise politique
syrienne comme l'a exprimé vladimir
poutine se fera politiquement et avec le
départ des forces étrangères et
alexandre lavrentiev a ajouté le
spécialiste de la question syrienne
pour le kremlin la dir ans y compris
donc les états unis interviennent israël
de nombreuses années intervient
également en syrie par des bombardements
mais curieusement n'est ce pas eh bien
le pouvoir s'il ya le pouvoir russe
laisse faire parce que cela avec
détriment de l'allier iranien qui a été
nécessaire pour combattre au sol mais
dont on ne veut pas de présence dans le
long terme en syrie merci beaucoup qu'on
votera décryptage gérard vesper
directeur de recherche à l
la fondation d'études pour le
moyen-orient